we can't just flip a switch and make it
better
the reality is that we inherited a
system an immigration system that was
deeply broken
vice president kamala harris is the
border czar but she says the migrant
crisis isn't her fault all-time high
border cross crossings a new caravan
headed north as we speak all happening
under her watch fox news contributor
trump joins us now larry great to see
you as always look how much longer can
they blame your father-in-law when
polling shows the american people know
what's going on they see right through
this
yeah they absolutely do um and it's
almost laughable this response from vice
president kamala harris that somehow
donald trump is to blame go back to
january of this year you did not see the
number of people illegally crossing our
southern border like you do now actually
under donald trump we had a secure
border had the biden harris
administration left everything alone
that donald trump had put in place we
would be in a much different position
right now but everyone knows that joe
biden and kamala harris ran on an open
borders policy remember every single one
of the democrats on stage during the
primaries raising their hands for free
health care for illegal immigrants they
all but invited people from that from
all around the world that wanted to come
here illegally to come now under this
administration we're now paying
reparations of up to 450 000
per person to illegal immigrants it is
absolutely preposterous that this has
anything to do with donald trump if they
wanted to fix it and kamala harris i'll
give you some advice the flip the switch
you need to flip is to go back to the
trump era policies because those were
actually working so no one buys this i
don't know who gave her the advice to
use this as her you know tactic to get
out of this question but probably the
wrong person to blame when donald trump
had one of the most secure borders and
we now have one of the most poorest yeah
and you look at the polling laura and in
one of the areas where president biden
pulls the lowest is on the immigration
issue so it's a wonder why he hasn't
changed his stance because it's hurting
him politically we also want to get to
president biden had this very long three
and a half hour conversation with
chinese president xi jinping on monday
and apparently the president didn't ask
him about the origins of kovid here's
jen saki on that front listen
did he ask president xi
to cooperate specifically with this u.s
intel agency-led investigation into the
origins of covet peter it's clear that
that's what we want that's what we've
been pressing on
yeah it's clear that that's what they
want but it doesn't sound like they had
an in-depth conversation about it at all
despite the fact that hundreds and
thousands of americans have died what's
your reaction on that front
i mean is it clear i think you have to
be very specific when you want something
from someone like the leader of china
and the the fact that joe biden
apparently did not even talk about the
thing that has upended everyone's lives
not just in america but all around the
world something that we we are still
continuing to feel the impact of life is
not yet totally back to normal for
anyone anywhere and it probably won't be
for a very long time if it ever does get
back there i mean it's terrible but it's
not surprising we know that china has
been very lucrative for the biden family
we knew back during the campaign and we
warned everyone about this that joe
biden would be soft on china that he
would not hold president president xi
accountable for anything you look at the
difference by the way between how donald
trump dealt with uh china and the way
that joe biden deals with china they are
light years apart they do not fear joe
biden
at all and so you know it's not
surprising that he is not pressing them
on anything but it is terrible and very
upsetting as an american to see this
lara trump have a great weekend we
appreciate you getting up with us and
talking to our viewers as you often do
on fridays
thanks lara speaking hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now